it happened just hours before the
opening of the Turkish Parliament
the attackers arrived at the minister of
interior building in Ankara in a Light
commercial vehicle
one of them carrying a russian-made
rocket launcher got out of the car and
directly headed towards the building's
guard Tower
the other with an American-made amp4
assault rifle used the car as a shield
thanks to the determination of our
security forces the moment that the
attackers got out of their vehicle they
started to shoot at them one of the
terrorists detonated a suicide vest and
the other was shot in the head without
having an opportunity to detonate
himself
Turkish authorities say the weapons used
in this attack were provided by the US
and Russia to the Kurdish ypg armed
group in Syria an American Ally in the
fight against isil
MPS inside Parliament were returning to
work after their summer break where they
are expected to ratify Sweden's entry
into NATO
to the opening of the church Parliament
there will be a voting about the
participation or acceptance of Sweden to
Nato and there are terrorist
organizations in Sweden being supported
by Sweden and they are against the
participation of Civilian to Nato as
well so that might be a kind of incident
which is trying to affect the decision
of the Turkish parliamentarians as well
police say the attackers stole the
vehicle and killed its driver in kaisin
a city 260 kilometers southeast of
Ankara before launching the attack
during a speed of Wireless in 2015 and
2016 the Turkish Capital saw bombings
targeting military personnel and
civilians killing nearly 150 people
the government blamed isil and pkk and
outlawed Kurdish armed group
people in Ankara are worried about more
attacks Jesus said that Al Jazeera and
Al Jazeera Cinema has just arrived in
Ankara and is joining us now live so
cinem the pkk claiming responsibility
for the attack bring us up to speed with
the latest
well yes Foley since the morning no one
has claimed the responsibility and the
technically this is uh this is a period
of long hours for the pkk to claim the
responsibility however the pkk media
reported that hpg which is called a
people's defense units an offshoot of
the pkk claimed the responsibility of
the attack and in a statement that was
also published on pkk's news outlets the
hpg the hpg group
perpetrated this incident to give a
warning to the Turkish Parliament who
who that was meant to convince today
after 2 pm today was the first session
of the winter 2023 part Turkish
Parliament and Turkish security
officials have been conducting a very
tight operations against the pkk inside
turkey and Outside Inside turkey and
outside turkey and mainly in the a
northern Iraq Kurdish Regional
government area for such a long time
this is how the interior Ministry
managed to wipe out the pkk out of its
borders but the according to Turkish
officials and Turkish politicians the
source of what they call terrorism must
be stopped and today when Turkish
president spoke during the opening
ceremony of the Turkish parliament's
first day he mentioned that took his
fight against what the government calls
terrorism will continue until the last
terrorist is eliminated right and this
is a situation many many suspected that
it was the pkk already yeah the finger
of blame was already being pointed at
the pkk the attack the timing of course
significant because it came as a new
Parliament is starting in Turkey its new
term what could be the motive behind the
attacks in him
uh well Folly of course the parliament
apparently according to apa hpg
statement the parliament it was aimed to
warn the parliament to stop these uh
anti-pkk operations uh to release pkk
leader Abdullah because pkk sympathizers
or pkk members believe that Abdullah who
has been a prison since late 1990s is in
isolation and they believe Turkish
government
Army is an occupier that's why this is
this is a resistance note by them
against the Turkish government and in
the Press notes they they publish it's
they say we could have we could do more
harm if we change the hour of this
perpetration we just wanted to give a
warning just a few hours later we if we
did this attack we could we could harm
all the parliament members right now I'm
very close to where the attack happened
on my right side behind me is the
interior Ministry entrance where the
explosion happened and this area is full
of ministerial buildings including
defense ministry as well Turkish
Parliament and it was a Sunday there
wasn't a collateral damage if it if this
attack happened during the weekday of
course everything could have been worse
but of course there are some other
motives as in our report that was aired
just minutes ago one of the biggest
headlines that the Turkish Parliament
will be discussing as it opened today is
the NATO membership of Finland and
turkey accuses a Sweden sorry and turkey
accuses Sweden for supporting the pkk
and another thing which is very
important just two weeks ago
in the Kurdish Regional area of Northern
of Iraq the Albert airport was targeted
by drones and the Iraqi authorities
Kurdish authorities said that that run
to go from Turkey Turkey never
officially claimed this drone attack in
that area but we heard defense minister
accusing the PUK leader Buffalo Taliban
for cooperating with the pkk and he said
we warned them many times so apparently
there is a tension in the region as well
back to you Foley thank you very much to
them for the updates reporting their
life from Ankara